hello there reject nation greg and john
here today thanks so much for clicking
on this video if you want to catch the
full-length watchalongs that we do for
superman and lois become a super sexy
reject today and check out everything we
gotta offer over there at a patreon
if you don't want to do that leave a
like
you can subscribe and click on
notification bell to get notified when
our reaction for the next episode
superman lowest is up i think the boys
at prepper for helping us edit down
these highlights lastly i want to thank
you guys for not being as mean as you
you probably wanted to be in our
comments uh for not really digging the
last episode fan favorite out of
all the episodes you know there's only
one we haven't looked okay just one i
loved it in concept so let's watch this
one and let's move past gotta redeem
ourselves let's move past it we're gonna
like this no matter what yeah he will
lie to you guys
don't no more honesty here honesty gets
you in trouble
for him
oh boy what if he gets powers what if
they emerge and it just works yeah
what do you mean you're here for me
so we can meet
oh no
no
whoa
no looks like the weak one got the
powers here
oh
oh dang
clark come on buddy
kill your sucks
beat the [ __ ]
you can't stop what's coming
oh no he's not paralyzed or something is
he
he might have done some serious damage
to him yeah well that's a lot to process
hmm anderson is dead shut up we're
watching this our family was a disaster
to put it mildly oh he's fine okay
i don't think they've been rough between
us
but none of that matters and i'm not
gonna let anything happen to you
ah dude you're over texting now one more
that'll that'll do the trick i'm not
sure i have any tech that'll even work
did your mother say anything else that
could be helpful this is all new to her
too
john oh boy oh no visions
what'd you see
you were a big trouble young man
go to your room
clarge hey
oh
i'm so sorry i i really really have to
go
okay
it's just things have been crazy lately
and i've got to fix this thing at the
farm no totally um
we'll catch up another time moana oh
i get it we're not friends anymore
god damn it now he's got two problems ah
i think priorities should be
talking a lot
yup
we want that seed until she was hurt
she probably wanted to talk about
winning the election
she won
oh
maybe i should just go over there later
and smooth things over for you
no this is a problem only superman could
i need to make a grand gesture
okay well clearly i didn't want candace
to get in trouble well maybe she should
have
she was selling drugs that is exactly
why i didn't say anything because you
asked me a question and you don't even
listen to what i have to say and lose
her house say say that because i lied to
protect someone else
and he lied to protect his own secret
that secret keeps this family safe it
allows you to have a normal life one
that isn't in the shadow of me being
superman if that's what the secret's
doing it's doing a pretty crap job
i know that look
jordan was texting me non-stop last
night and as soon as i messaged back
nothing but radio silence
good
gotta run the hook
he always seems so excited to see you
yeah i could literally feel him trying
to get rid of me
he didn't even mention the election i
don't get it he's your biggest supporter
he's on your ex-husband's side that's
right he voted for eric
pencilled him in i packed some boxes to
go inside of your car but
i don't think we should put those boxes
in my car
why not
oh because
i would um
rather oh
i have the mover in yours
nice
your dad and i both agreed you've earned
this
oh hey sarah huh i'll meet you over at
the office okay okay
uh
best thing to do for your kids during a
divorce oh yeah i give them a nice get
in the car so they can act out
yeah you know dad agreed but mom paid
for it
it's a
letter i wrote sarah
you wrote her a letter
what is she taking a prairie wagon to
the 1880
okay that's
bro it's such a private letter yeah it's
basically a journal entry
[Music]
oh
no no
aren't you gonna say anything about the
car
kent men just ignoring the cushing's
today
see you later
[Applause]
[Music]
sarah's gonna learn the truth to protect
her after lana gets kidnapped
jonathan
what are you doing here
a lot more than necessary dude
[Music]
oh
i should have just kidnapped her yes way
way easier
less messy
oh god jonathan's already got a bad
reputation yeah
yeah
can imagine what this is gonna do
anyway the older you get the more you
realize
everyone is dealing with something
speaking of what's going on with
jonathan not me
i'm good well when i saw him earlier it
looked like he was going to a rave out
in the matrix
walking on my street as i pulled out it
looked like he was going to candice's
tell your mom i dropped by
i have to go
family stuff
because my best friend is in danger okay
well maybe if you didn't care so much
about keeping your secrets jonathan
upstairs right now clark oh [ __ ] go
find her every parent knows you are just
pushing your son to merge
this is all on you guys
one merge at a time
i think something might have happened to
my mom
oh snaps she never showed up at the
office so i went back to the house to
look for her and she wasn't there i mean
john john was the neighborhood maybe
he he knew where she went i talked to
him when he got home he said he went
straight to candace more secrets
we will find out what happened but the
best thing for you to do right now is go
back to her office and i will reach out
the moment i hear of anything okay tell
her
it's a bad time but this is important i
need to tell you how i really feel
jordan my mom is missing look look
instead of stumbling over my word
i wrote it all down
everything i've been trying to say to
you but couldn't
jordan
i don't want your letter
oh
but he spent so much time on it it's
like a full page so what it's like some
dimensional rift that we see on the
earth
there's more to it than that
clark mentioned the middle ground like a
negative zone completely devoid of
diamonds the naked zone
i know that you've been struggling
got kicked out of school that jonathan
is not me and that your parents are
worried about you you
don't know my parents
you are being vague
let me clarify what are we doing clerk
the secret is destroying everything we
care about what are you saying lois
maybe we need to trust our family to
know the right thing to do with the
truth oh god
john
clark get on the news
tell them
i'm taking off my glasses now
then like an industrial freezer like a
big big freezer that sounds like the old
slaughterhouse sometimes
i wonder how long it took him to figure
out how to zip out of the house without
leaving a big hole
i'm not gonna let you harm her
i was counting on that
[Music]
freeze it nice
oh
i'll be over soon
what is going on right now [ __ ]
come on
i'll be back soon
i don't want to watch a show called and
lois
[Laughter]
but anyone could fill the first half
it's an anthology series
she's here for lana grosso for superman
no dad i just got a horrible song
because i can't just go
good work bunk
jordan the only one who could stop him
god damn right brother fight
cool dad's not coming to stop me this
time
you start with one of the heart too you
know
yeah
you're not going anywhere
oh crap
good job
more powers great
now
come on you got boxing lessons remember
what your granddad taught you
punch through the bag son
don't stop it keep screaming
let him know that he failed his son just
like my father failed me
all right
oh my god go faster though
two
oh
oh
nice
come on jordan
oh nice nice work buddy
[Music]
and lois
oh damn dude
yeah
i get the drop
come on buddy
figure this out
oh why'd you bring the other one back
yeah
because you got to show he's better than
bizarro superman
this is for my brother
[Music]
we're going to lotus
[Laughter]
all of us together we're going to tell
her as family
please reveal it by putting your glasses
on
[Music]
would you steal clark's glasses
i mean if this story were to get out
they would have to deal with the fallout
i'm pretty sure the lois lane that i
know
she can handle it
it's not lost i'm worried about
you're a good friend
why do you
maybe you want to come in
i'm not cheating if it's superman
it's a bit called pants
you were right about the letter i'm
sorry
oh
read it jordan
no it's her idea i want to hear what she
thinks oh
you were gonna tell sarah your secret
and you knew about this
why does
everything have to be an act of defiance
with you two don't you get that we are
on your side you not get that we're on
yours
feels like we keep drifting apart as a
family maybe we're not that close to
begin with ouch this decision would
affect all of us
if you're all okay with it absolutely
yes
okay then
uh
wish me luck oh he didn't cut her off
but sarah i can't know [ __ ] about you
i still don't get it what happened like
i said i just needed some air and
somehow
the day got away from me
oh mom that doesn't really honey i need
to go
start by lasering her car
i have something to tell you
i do want to hear what you have to say
but i have had the longest day
i was with you
what are you talking about
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
i tell her you love her
superman
[Music]
beautiful shot yeah
hope nobody drives by
now i will kill you
i have to destroy you now
that was
good
that was that was really good i liked a
lot
did you i did
that's good enough
so like what thoughts did you have
i mean i don't know coming out of the
last episode which was very much sort of
like a i like this in concept let it go
this episode i thought did a really nice
job of returning to you know a good
balance of the tension and the emotional
debate i feel like we're requesting
toward the end of the season here
and
even though i guess
i mean it has been building up and
jordan has been wanting to tell her i
feel like this is easily the most sort
of focus the whole like do we tell
everybody do we maintain the secret
where the secret is ripping this family
apart but i i liked what they made out
of that and i liked
just the sort of bumper cars of ever of
all the circumstances crashing into each
other and the hard decisions and the
moments where you do get the question
like man
lois is just taking the situation into
her own hands and telling sarah a lie
with the best of intent you know and
kind of encouraging her to leave to
safety but also this isn't exactly
what's going on you know like i feel
like they gave
some really nice nuances uh to the
stakes and circumstances overall
and some good action you know some good
uh
uh you know shows down
i thought it was it was a it was a nice
return
you mean
superman returns
yes he does
i
i don't dislike that movie
i thought it was all right
brandon ralph boyd spacey supporter
yeah give me kevin spacey and and uh and
and uh what's his name your boy uh you
know it'll come to me bye bye brian
singer yeah you're your buddy brian
singer yeah just give me those two
together and uh we're good
always
straight up g mm-hmm i want them to have
their own i mean spacey already has a
youtube channel but
i know i got notifications
every christmas time so i'm gonna like
that video before i even watch it
my turn
[Laughter]
build it up brew
a strong opinion
i do
i do i gotta i gotta be controversial oh
it's a hot little take there
normally you wanna start with positives
i did
and then you go to negatives eventually
if there are negatives
you can't force it
now i'm gonna start
with the thing i care the least about
okay
just to give this video some edge
some
morgan edge
i think the
storyline with
john adams
and
natalie
yes it is i know it's john henry so john
and and natalie
was
not that interesting
boom it's on repeat story
they're out yep
wow what do you do greg why don't you
kick it off oh my god man shots fall i
was gonna think about everyone's gonna
be like what do you hate john henry
irons
i don't hate john henry irons but
i
don't really own any other stories
you know what i mean um give her some
actual character breath
i'm always complaining
i'm a complainer
she's a complainer
rightfully so her world was obliterated
she's got trauma i get it
but you could still wouldn't exactly be
all mr positive
if my world was all obliterated and i
had to
see my doppelganger mom banging the
doppelganger guy who destroyed my mom in
the world i get it
so
you know we get somehow it's still
played just like a
annoyed teenager and it just bothers me
all right
so i feel like you could easily write
more for them that's right main takeaway
from this episode
that
boom
on some positives
emo jonathan was better
yes by long shot more is actually kind
of menacing
i appreciated that quite a bit
that's a good point it is a great solid
point you just want to acknowledge that
point everyone yeah man it was
he was sinister and he threatened again
the secret so there's even more stakes i
mean once you start getting involved
like that and making it like jonathan
did it you knew cat was out of the bag
enough cat out of
bag
meow
so
having that situation was
awesome it's pretty sick
i thought he was going to kill her at
one point
even evil lana was kind of scary don't
know why she ran away yeah i was like if
you can still couldn't just punch them
and
you killed them you couldn't obliterate
just like wow
[ __ ] you bam you're dead you're gonna be
training them in a heart what do you
mean let me i'll come back for you why
are you why come back
doesn't look like that xk is actually
hurting you that much you're able to zip
off after you have some strength left to
so
that was good um
uh
i like when it balances though
you know
dramatic [ __ ] with the
high stakes world ending stuff
sometimes it was a little funky to me
like
jordan why are you arguing like your own
personal
like
teen hormone breakup emotions right now
i'm like i get it
again i get it
but why are we why are you dedicating so
much why is this your main concern
over evil jonathan possibly kidnapping
and murdering your
the your girlfriend your mom
yeah like that's that's there should be
nothing else discussed at this moment
yeah i feel like maybe the only thing
talks about there are family concerns
about the secret and everything else but
i feel like yeah i feel like you could
probably see
the importance of certain heights of
stakes when like yeah
your brother's doppelganger could kill
anyone in town in a very loud and
obvious way sometimes it has to be like
an aaron sorkin thing where
you're like in the middle of debating
and then like you you spit out a couple
things
you know of like why'd you though why
are you talking or we don't have time
for this fine
and then just that that's there to be
acknowledged later
you know when things calm down
but sometimes it was like dude i side
with you but you're also annoying me
because this is shouldn't be the topic
of conversation right now
but
but let the record show yes
did i read that correctly you did sir
let it show
this is one of jordan's coolest episodes
simultaneously man
when he grabbed that fist
and then punched him and he started
zipping off like when you you throw an
action figure
it was great and they flew into the sky
it's beautiful
bird it's a plane no it's jordan
it's up in the sky whooping ass love
that realization was like i'm flying oh
god and they started falling
with style amen
woody
so when he starts falling down and and
then
um
that's you know that point oh yeah
it was a really it was a really
rewarding moment and i did agree with
him you know i was i was there
i like i like this
i'd like to see a superman show that
talks so much about
you know the purpose of a secret what is
the and argues it is it the right call
because we're so used to it being the
right call and just like natural to any
superhero existence pretty much
yeah and if it's out in the open it
usually means you gotta mess up superman
yeah that's usually what the medium is
if it's if it's out there it means
there's something wrong but but lana
proved herself with being like oh and i
can't tell anyone about this i've got to
protect the kids and right then and
there so i thought that going to that
point there were so many reasons to tell
her a
lana doppelganger
out there clearly super injured healing
and
on the brink of death she didn't break
her death but
it's time to recover when she does it's
going to be pure vengeance
and so you have that and then jonathan
and and um
all the reasons to tell a secret i i
thought
was so well debated and the way they
landed on that conclusion was so
beautiful and the reminder that lana and
clark are actually best friends
[Music]
was uh was something that made it sweet
and let's see from like a boy girl
perspective where it's not like
it's a rewarding thing you know i i i
it's always rewarding when you find out
that
the guy who's into the girl
actually who's like the superhero but
his identity secret and the only thing
he wants to do is tell her
like tells the girl writing usually
finds out in some super heroic moment
and then they fall in love and have kids
and whatever
and this was unique because it wasn't
the other situation of like the best
friend finding out thinking it's cool or
the best friend being like what did you
tell me oh my god you lied to me for so
long they managed to make something
sweet and nuanced from him telling his
female best friend
and in a way that felt
wondrous and not like
you know
sexual or romantic it was just
friendship
i thought was great i thought was really
nicely done i thought this was a
beautiful episode overall all joking
aside yeah i thought this was a great
episode i wasn't really too bothered by
jordan i was messing with you guys
yeah i thought this was a really good
episode and uh
well it's an interesting dovetail for
those two because jordan has the similar
kind of moment like i mean him and
superman
clark and lana is a very similar moment
to jordan and sarah except one goes the
complete opposite direction
which i appreciated yeah i wonder like
we gotta i don't know part of me feels
like that that cat's gonna come out of
the bag before the season's done but
even then i like that they allow the
characters to be sloppy in ways that
make sense like you're sitting there
going oh no jordan no now is not the
time
uh but they still let him make that
mistake and it's a very honest mistake i
feel like so
yeah you just gotta get it out there man
that's true try it's true
it's tough when you're a teenager and
you're i feel like you're about to lose
someone you get obsessive and passionate
that's true desperate
forget it man
adults do it
so what's the
teenage boy from doing it not at all
yeah
i like that they that they allowed that
nuance to exist
it's like it always feels like it's not
the time then when's a good time it has
to wait till after the brothers can we
skip brother john you know when's a good
time
wow so it's maybe not right when
someone's like rushing to make sure
their mom's not dead
maybe
maybe
but it's but but from the perspective
when you finally find out what's in the
letter you're like well okay
maybe he's gonna confess that he's got
powers and [ __ ] so
yeah and it's it's cool how they're
how they they learn from the
doppelganger world in ways you know like
clark sees that as a as a thing to fear
that the problem is the fact that
secrets out but it's not like they need
to announce it to the world
yeah it's not like they have to indulge
in it they could just not act so heavily
to hide it all the time
yeah just depend
like there are more that you can trust
yeah
that's a good way to put that
that's a good way to put that
freaking john henry iron's nose i know
i know
he's like family to them who is always
nearly dying
dude he's got something in that immune
system
his blood just repairs it you are a body
at a rapid level you're so prone to
disaster and yet so resilient
yeah and his heels so well
he's gonna have his whole head's gonna
be a scar by like season four though
he's got so many more scars now
uh yeah i thought this was a great
episode and everyone should like it and
if they if you don't like it there's
clinically something wrong with you and
you get that checked out
all right guys thanks for being here
snl
pete davidson
that's superman everyone wants
i don't know oh no
who else in the snow cast could do it
scarlett johansson's white husband oh
colin jost yeah that's fair enough
actually
colin jost
keenan thompson
jj from directs michael j as superman
matter of fact why is cracking smart ass
superman
that'd be cool i would love it
change it up yeah
hey man
eventually i want there to be an amish
superman
i will not save anyone in a major city
or out of a vehicle
or anywhere where there's electric
lights
superman of
the backwoods
meta knight superman
oh that'd be good that'd be a good
fortress of solitude
hey
amen
bye
[Music]
you